all right this is a super interesting
story and a very different um
uh uh sort of military-related story
than what many of us have become
accustomed to
yesterday the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff general mark milley
was asked uh questions by republican
congressman
matt gates about the u.s military
examining critical race theory now the
the term examining
is really the appropriate term
understanding
marxian economics doesn't make you a
marxist
and much the same way examining critical
race theory
doesn't make you someone who
guides their philosophy or runs a
military on the basis of critical race
theory although you may learn something
that's relevant or furthers your
understanding or maybe not but the point
is
simply understanding something examining
it
learning about it doesn't actually
dictate your political philosophy
and uh matt gates and others
were just uh getting after general mark
milley
and he delivered a concise
and very astute explanation
of why i mean forget about just critical
race theory there's a bigger issue here
which is the right he doesn't say the
right but
i've been pointing out the right seems
to fail to understand
the value of diverse knowledge
for its own sake rather than
necessarily as a tool of indoctrination
so let's take a look at this clip this
is general mark milly
super super interesting stuff you'll see
the camera if you're watching go to matt
gates at one point who's just sort of
shaking his head and he
doesn't like it but he seems to know
he's being schooled right now take a
look mr chair and thank you gentlemen
for joining us today
i know my time is very precious but i
would like to yield some of my time to
general milley because i know that he
had
some comments that he wanted to make
when representative gates was talking
as well as mr waltz about a similar
subject of the stand down
and race theory would you like a minute
or so to comment on that do you remember
what we were
what your line of questioning or thought
was there um
sure um first of all on the
issue of critical race theory etc i'll
obviously have to get much smarter on
whatever the theory is but i do think
it's important
actually for those of us in uniform
to be open-minded and be widely read and
the united states military academy is a
university
and it is important that we train and we
understand
uh and i i want to understand white rage
understand what he's pointing out here
right the military trains for many
contingencies which never happen
the military trains to understand
circumstances uh which may be good
bad neutral or irrelevant because that's
what you do you prepare
you learn you understand similarly when
you apply that and say hey this is a
university
you learn things in university from
math i mean listen have i used calculus
2
in my work life no but understanding it
and going through it has been
extraordinarily valuable
in terms of now i understand how do we
even learn
math at that level which is not a
particularly high level but i'm not i'm
not bragging but i'm just saying
i'm not using it but it's still useful
and much the same way we should be
seeing
some of this these ideologies and and
theories as well
right now that's an academic it's it's
the most basic
thing right about what we what learning
is i want to understand it
so what is it that caused thousands of
people to assault
this building and try to overturn the
constitution of the united states of
america what caused that
right i want to find that out i want to
maintain an open mind here and i do want
to analyze it
it's important that we understand that
because our soldiers sailors airmen
marines and guardians
they come from the american people so it
is important by the way guardians that's
the space force trump thing i i he you
know he has to say it it just it sounds
so weird to hear it that the leaders now
and in the future do understand it i've
read miles seitang
i've read i've read karl marx i've read
lenin that doesn't make me a communist
this thi i mean this is the this is
literally the example i gave earlier in
the show
when i was at the university of
massachusetts amherst one of the few
then uh economics programs which
seriously taught what the class was
marxian economics with the with the late
uh
stephen resnick a co-author with richard
wolff
in many articles and even books i
believe um
it didn't turn me into a marxist but i i
learned what is the theory what is the
genesis we
we read mark there was nothing dangerous
going on it's called being informed
uh and to hear mark milley say it i have
to tell you is is fantastic
so what is wrong with understanding
having some situational understanding
about the country for which we are here
to defend
and i personally find it offensive that
we are accusing
the united states military our general
officers our commission non-commissioned
officers
of being quote woke or something else
because we're studying some theories
that are out there that was started at
harvard law school years ago and it
proposed
that there were laws in the united
states anti-bellum laws prior to the
civil war
that led to a power differential with
african-americans that were
three-quarters of a human by the way the
general knows much more about all of
these topics than matt gates but that
probably doesn't come as a surprise to
anybody
being when this country was formed and
then we had a civil war and emancipation
proclamation
to change it and we brought it up to the
civil rights act in 1964 it took another
100 years to change that
so look it i do want to know and i
respect your service and you and i are
both green berets
but i want to know and it matters by the
way it's not
matt gates that's the green beret it's a
different congressman who's there
military in the discipline and cohesion
of this military
and i thank you for the opportunity to
make a comment on that thank you general
so the general is completely right this
is just called thinking this is called
being a student of things
this is called learning uh understanding
and um it it makes absolute uh
perfect sense that uh this would be the
perspective that an
entity like the military would take and
um it doesn't mean the military becomes
woke in the negative sense of the
of the term now just just to give you
one reaction to this which is so funny
after this last night laura ingraham on
fox news
responded to this and she said the
reason this happened is because of
democrats and the military-industrial
complex
this is she's like a trapeze artist
she's a she's a contortionist
i don't know how this is what she comes
up with but let's listen the active duty
service men and women about that sir
now somehow i don't think general milley
would ever speak
in this dismissive tone that he took
today
to his chinese counterparts not the way
he spoke to congressman waltz who
questioned him
what i have a question for the general
why would anyone risk his or her life
for a country
that's systemically racist one that
brutalizes minorities
this is what you call black and white
thinking
let's assume for a second that it wasn't
just that mark milley said
let's understand critical race theory
imagine for a second that what mark
milley said
was the military will now see critical
race theory as its guiding
explanation and system for understanding
the country
that's not what he said but imagine that
mark milley went as far as to say that
now laura ingram says why would anyone
be in the military to defend a country
that's structurally racist well
you underst for those who subscribe to
critical race theory
presumably the next step is how do we
fix it
and the same or similar motivation that
would lead someone
if they join the military for the right
reasons which is well for
if i mean we can argue about whether the
military is used in this way but
if you join not to go and kill people as
some some do but most don't
if you join the military to try to make
the country better
and if you believe critical race theory
you would then want to
change things to make the country better
in both cases you're trying to make the
country better so hurt this black and
white thinking of
if there's any systemic racism then you
wouldn't even be in the military because
you'd not want to defend a country
that's systemically racist
it's just gutter black and white
thinking why would any country respect
us or follow our lead if that's who we
are
those are some of the questions he
should probably think about before he
touts the value
of teaching far left marxist racist
ideology to our troops
and again all he touted was we want to
understand what are the conversations
that are happening
and what are the arguments being made he
never said
let's become a woke critical race theory
military that
had he said that it would be a different
discussion the fact is millie
has made his choice and he's chosen to
indulge the radical whims of democrats
he'll do everything they tell him as
long as they keep the military
industrial complex flush with cash
and of course that's just so silly given
that
you know military-industrial complex
is almost as big of an issue in terms of
blind support from democrats than from
republicans
a little bit less you do hear some
democrats say
we've got to pare this down so for laura
ingram now to say well that
this is all happening he's taking a left
perspective
because of democrats funneling money
into the military-industrial complex
republicans do far more of it so it's it
makes no sense one way or the other
and very interesting to see the
statements by general mark milley
one of our sponsors is rise the
science-based app that makes it easy to
improve your sleep and your daily energy
rise helps you figure out what are your
sleep needs helps you achieve your best
possible sleep
through two core principles of sleep
science the idea of sleep debt meaning
how much sleep you owe your body
and circadian rhythms dictating your
energy levels each morning
the rise app tells you how long you'll
be groggy
what your energy peaks will be during
the day when you should start winding
down for bed
for optimal sleep i've been using the
app on my phone every day for a while
now
and i started noticing improved sleep
and energy within
just a few nights and it's giving me a
really good
understanding of the relationship
between my sleep
and when i'm sleeping and my daytime
energy my audience can try rise for free
for a whole week by going to rise
science.com pacman the link is
underneath this video